the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
you
a lot of the moment in this moment about
20 of them are part of this co-op plug
the solar woman have talked about that
and these women basically they get
grants from different funding sources to
research sustainable energy options so
one of the things that they do is they
make their own solar panels and it's the
people in the village can buy these
either with money or with hours spent
working in the coop so we decided that
even though they're making 16 watt
panels it's does not match that but even
though they're making 60 watt panels
like these they also all have cell
phones but a lot of them around the grid
so they also need ways of charging these
things out that solar power is a good
way of doing this so what they're doing
right now to make these is for tenants
but basically they take the smaller
cells which for 8 by 15 centimeters and
these are rejection and not as efficient
as
and state yourself that we might use
here but they're much cheaper so they
used those they might hand soldered them
all together line them up put liquid
silicone over them and then put a glass
piece over it and then encapsulate it
all and make it look much nicer than
what you saw on the previous slide so
this is like you know a much smaller
much nicer looking one that is made in
China and important but it's available
for $20 in managua about three average
from the time we stayed in and so these
are very difficult to get a pretty
expensive but they also would like to be
able to make them there so that it's
about the same price but it's more kind
of accessible it employ some people and
isn't there's more sustainable so that's
what we set out to do so as was
mentioned they do have access to solar
cells and so but I'm questioning to see
what happens right now is to make the
cell phone judgment they need to cut
these cells and what they do is
basically they
what they sell for bonds and then the
Ducks tendon series so that will digits
add up so you can get up to six votes
watchin thieve with this process what
ends up happening is you end up losing a
lot of the cells just because the way
the method that they used to cut them is
not foolproof and so you end up racking
a lot of the cells and when we talk to
them we realized that they waste about
half the cells become which means that
if they wanted to if they need to use
nine cells that end up using 18 a big
waste tab so we figured that if we could
somehow step up the voltage given by
three original cells they call these
original cells if you could step up the
voltage given by three original cells to
their wide 5 volts to charge our cell
phone without affecting them it would
save a lot of time and money and so what
he decided to do was connect three of
the cells in series so you get a 1.5
volt output and then it had that output
1 through your circuit which stepped it
up to 5 volts now this circuit basically
works like this you have certain
situations but you know you have fun in
putting here I add 1.5 volts it goes
through your op amp extension up to one
point two five or 3.3 I depending on how
it's connected graph but opposite we
need five so
these are capacitors and inductor and a
Zener diode is you know this used to
make sure that both it goes in one
direction only and then so basically
these two beads have about this
difference of 5 volts across them when
connected to the solar panels in optimal
lighting and what we did was we then so
this is we surveyed what kind of cell
phones tapes and realize that for the
most part if there are no kids and this
is the most common form that's available
then everyone the adapter that he used
to charge this cutout port and attached
it yeah if you look at Hartford or you
notice that so
so the orange and black wires are these
basically and then they connect to your
report and then basically the idea is
that you plug it in we're not in
sunlight and use this it's a way to make
sure that you're always facing the Sun
openly but there a lot of notches along
Thersites and so basically you've wedged
this in and then you can change the
angle of your petal
so this is just a very rudimentary cost
breakdown of what our medias limit our
cellphone charger to cost and basically
a lot I mean finally like we this is the
number that we came we were trying to
shoot for $20 and we slightly above that
but we figure that there's the ways to
optimize costs and that is very viable
for them to get this for $20 yeah
basically this is just to give you an
idea how expensive all the components
are I don't want to run through each one
of them just but so I just mentioned a
real quick thing we're also including $4
for labor so if we're so even though it
is that everyone says it is produced
locally and had it is providing
employment whereas the Internet China me
right exactly like you animate oneself
or maybe others but like ones that they
don't provide any service have been
coming to the people in and yeah so this
is just to give you a an idea cops break
down this is just a blown-up image of
etiquette again just to give you an idea
of the components that we used
essentially is like this circuit is
enclosed by this casing right here so
it's that so good they took people
underneath this chica monkey in it so
you can any but you can see in that
image and the next image okay right so I
mean like I said this is your awkward
moment alone so please go into just okay
when Judge cellphone and the actual
circuitry so this is talking about like
why we it like this we decided to use a
breadboard because when we talked to
Morrow who was our community but this is
that he told us that they do have access
to credit works but don't have access to
protocols which we were still planning
on using and so we decided to stick with
the breadboard model and we also like we
figured we asked for the various
components and they are available the
only component that we could actually
see having a ship ship that is this
but since they already shipped solar
cells there it would just be another
component to ship and start a walkie so
we think it's definitely viable so
that's that's why we decided to go with
the person popular
but before that can I just want to just
speak over a little bit about the site
in general why we chose to build it the
way we did first of all it's made out of
wood because the really low-key battle
material so first of all let's talk
about the solar panel so this is the
solar panel because we didn't have I
guess easy access to liquid silicone and
let me know in class they use we instead
use acrylic and a different method to to
glue the south anika in Nicaragua they
make these they're friendly they
customized for every application and so
we were talking to him on the phone he
already going to make some changes to
the initial design we had made and he
said he would like changing the hinges
and everything I'm sure it'll be made
out of aluminum and Sicily yeah so we
did - originally we wanted to make like
like stance so we could change the angle
and not just here but then we realized
that it we want to realize that many
easier to put something in here they
said how you can have nice so we just
came up with a notch it more just piece
of cut a piece of your pipe and you can
change the angle moreover we wanted to
create up and we don't put a techno
circuit so we're using case that around
frame with the - where is he now
additionally these are really two
switches so you do have another
cellphone you could switch the charger
and it's not another supplement and
another another recent way this this is
over here just in case of rain I mean
hopefully you have it outside you'll be
looking at outside for rain and because
of rains this is waterproof and it'll
also protect is so important and the
charger for at least enough temperature
coming gated if it's raining really hard
and great settings and sending it wet
but for that enough times we realize
this really should be protected right
and just like one said so like I said we
could also have another adapter going
out from the same leaves and we actually
do have the USB adapter that runs at the
same voltage that we did test but for
the purpose of the demonstration we
decided to go with an orchid because
it's the more locally available phone so
but we could potentially have a number
of different adapters shooting out there
it's all gonna be seen
so
so we're doing some testing and the past
couple of days to really see how much
power you get out of the cell phone and
using the lamp over there in testing let
me show you a demo kinda actually
actually it working as it does work do
you want actually a stretch don't just
get the pieces so here's the whole solar
panel fire satellite in wicked incident
to light
and
you connected
he's charging so it does work you got
scared for a second well there's no way
you stay charging it just has a little
right so yes so it does work however we
wanted to see how efficient it is and
how fast we will get it to actually work
unison we realize that um Boston Mason
is not the same as Nick and I were just
son with the narrator so we conducted
the tell a lot of different lights and
light output this is the output power of
the of the light of the of the solar
panels calculated by just measuring the
current and the voltage at the same time
on a solar panel and oh and the output
power is our power are these two leads a
calculated by measuring the current and
the voltage at the same time so as so we
don't get this then within
and so we then make a Center for the
efficiency and weary and this is for the
Boston said the power we're getting
right now if we estimated for any kind
of oil Sun we would be getting around
sixty five percent efficiency right now
we're getting about point two amps and
Buxton Queen yeah point zero 2 amps 20
milliamps yeah in Boston if we do we
extrapolated for how what we were
getting Nicaragua with this part of it
when you cut it what we'll be getting
around eighty to a hundred milliamps
which in the cell phone batteries are
about a hundred million so it would take
about ten hours to charge a cell phone
which is not ideal because we were 84 at
the beginning was for me for four hours
five hours we're expecting 200 they
survey said that a 200 milliamps would
be outputted from the circuit but
instead we're getting 95 so it's not as
efficient as we would like but it's
still work and right and just to explain
why it so scatterbug has a point i say
above the hundred percent
See Mom which is theoretically possible
that was just probably some guy the
times we were using the actual Sun and
so it probably changed a little bit in
between right
that's it think you're English pretty
much it yeah you guys many questions so
how did you estimate the Nicaraguan son
we took measurements while we were there
as far as like what voltage and current
output each thought was at around like
one o'clock yeah
all that started that will
a ten-hour issue
No the only thing I think of is that the
Sun moves and our yeah the user would
have to understand that they they would
have to move so it might actually be
longer than 10 out you know in optimal
zone it's 10 hour yeah the one thing we
noticed was when talking to people that
usually didn't actually charge it from
completely discharged to charged they
usually charge from about half charge so
it'd be more like five hours which is
more reasonable because that's more like
this man that Sun is usable in a day we
got mixed answers on that like we did
about 10 to 15 interviews of people and
asked that question and most people I
think on average said they charged it
about once a week there was one person
who said once every 15 days once once
every three days just depends how much
they use it it also I think depends on
how many cell phones they have in the
family yeah because we noticed that like
one time we had one cell phone for the
entire family so it obviously been a
pasta but if you have individual cell
phones they tend to last longer because
and so it really depends but for the
most part like the said hi people once a
week was away maybe twice a week I guess
I know a lot and most of them just um we
noticed just from living with the
families a lot of the times the cell
phone just stays in the house so that if
they receive a call so they can actually
still be sort of using it while it's
like charge could still be within
hearing shot so if they got a call they
can unplug it and answer it but they
can't like call was there while it's
charging right I mean it's actually
essentially they use a lot of stuff in
this assignment just because they don't
have an online connectivity so yeah
so just a little bit about the community
partner we worked with they are called
the suppressor there are human
development NGO based in Santa Ana they
work in rural areas and
try to improve the quality of life
through environmental and nutritional
education also microcredit opportunities
and general Community Development one of
the suppressors current projects is in
introducing rice cultivation in El
Salvador
both as a source of nutrition but also
as income generation and in order to
prepare us for consumption it needs to
be threshed and also deep husked and
current methods that the community uses
are very time and money intensive so our
design challenge is to develop a cheap
and local process that Dee husks writes
more successfully and conveniently the
most important product attributes that
we focused on or the efficiency and the
affordability of the product we our goal
was to make sure that in more than 90
percent of the rice was successfully
defunct while keeping the price of the
product under $2 we
so looked at cost and durability and
safety
and so after extensive research and some
brainstorming exercises we concluded
that the best approach to this design
challenge is to modify an existing
melina which is a corn mill you
currently used in the communities the
advantages are that it's already
available and it's being supplied by our
community partner and essentially what
we're proposing is in sir
material between the two metal plates of
de molina that would provide enough
friction to addy husk the rice grains
but at the same time prevent them for
broken and some of the challenges that
we're dealing with are the lack of
precision of the Molino and then also
the fact that it has friction so that it
wears the materials down so I'm going to
talk about the experimentation process
so initially our first problem with
deciding what kind of answer we wanted
to use so we looked at metal various
types of rubber and foam and leather and
when we were looking at these materials
were really evaluated them on the cost
and as a residue they were going to
leave on the rice how long it was going
to that so how durable and how available
that material was so when we did our
experiments are two main variables that
we were looking at were essentially the
type of material and also the tightness
of the Malena
so essentially the tightness was how
much space was going to exist in between
the insert in the middle place to
provide the adequate friction and when
we did our methodology our experiments
first we inserted the material and we
control the spacing by screwing the tab
all the way in until we could turn it
any tighter and then we turned it a
certain number of turns back out so we
knew how much space they were existent
in between the answer
and then we ran the race through the
Baleno and after we ran the race through
we us windowed it and we separated the
rice into a husk the when I was still
husk and if it had been the husk or
broken or the rice protocol's or the hub
of leftover hot servant proposed to me
and these pictures show the various
types of experiments we really did in
most quite an expensive process we
experiment with various different types
of materials we would use one material
and vary the number of turns
we might insert multiple layers of the
material to see if that changed anything
and also we would run the material the
brights through twice and see if that
changed the efficiency of the race
itself and ultimately what we decided
was that leather was the most
appropriate insert for us because when
we did different material inserts we
essentially found out that it wasn't so
much the material that matters but it
was the number of turns that was really
would change the process and the
efficiency and we knew that this
material had to be soft enough so that
the frictional and the torque wouldn't
break the material and but we also knew
it had to be very durable because we
didn't want it to wear away
the best option for us okay so we're
looking at La there we first decided
that we wanted to do unattached without
having to glue around here the leather
to them you know it allows for
flexibility for them you know use and
have cooler results and
be positive
toxic glue we also decided with brown
we didn't want anything those to process
or patented or
and we bought one piece man
because it was similar we had similar
results as tear mark Issa
it's obviously she
we're not including your appearance
so we actually were worried about
toxicity after
we could
exposure because chromium sex is the
most hazardous chemicals being used in
treatment and correction
in your body so
the bushes have enjoyed micrograms of
commander energy motors
and we found a that's a remote eating
another seven of these inserted is that
we don't think I do
we also found that there's not really
significant leather where we process
about seven half kilograms of right such
as a family as wealthy rights
consumption I'm using this concern
but
don't want that process so you can tell
it and stretched a little bit but other
than that there's no
where that we found so we wanted to
optimize the process after me
are
and so we process about 1/2 liters of
time and we do a whole bunch of
different
we really focused on the optimal
tightness Mulino and we did this by
looking at the percent that was tossed
in the perfumery
do
then we also attached five washer
suicide
this is a lot personally from August a
better control the spacing between the
metal over there so it really optimize
our tunas
without of more experimentation so it's
on that using the monkeys of leather
at 94 96 percent pots which is really
good
and sir optimal up
when he had our original product context
of solutions we found that this was fair
we have
three thousand
so our vision was one piece of leather
unattached to those the best four and a
half to five terms but the user can vary
that depending on what they want as
broken and versus
it's
very minimal costs about fifty fifty
cents per is there
Spector's we're normally but not too
much it's not so now that you've heard a
little bit of the decisions behind the
process I just want to take a little bit
through of what it might look like for
someone that's in the community and what
they would have to do to go what you use
of this process so first I'd have to get
a hold of a piece of leather and cut it
to the doughnut shape that would fit
into the shaft and if the Molino body
wasn't set up already they would you
know put it on the stand and proceeded
to put the leather on on the shaft and
put that on into through the main body
and then continue by you know adding the
reservoir up on top as well as the
handle on the side then the next the
next thing would be to add these washers
so that the this brace can hold the
shaft in the main body but it can still
be tighten enough and still leave enough
space for the leather to fit inside then
they would turn the knob all the way in
and then onion and then turn out the
specified four and a half to five turns
or according to their preference whether
they wanted broken rice or more broken
rice or more on how strikes and would
then crank away and put the rice in and
process and from there take separate the
husks from the grains bite we knowing it
using their preferred method and from
there just as a side note we also found
that when we're when we're doing our
more detailed experiments we found that
or to separate the broken ranks versus
the whole grains we found that when we
were shaking it back and forth in the in
those says the unhusked rice actually
came up to the top just because it's a
little bit larger and so that sort of
gives a natural separation between the
ones that still had the husks on and the
ones that didn't and so from there we so
what we're going to be suggesting is to
you know put the winnowed rice into a
into a container should I get back and
forth a little bit and from there the
rice will then collect to the top and
get to be able to sort of scoop it out
and that's what gives us our 96%
efficiency and that's another
contribution to the process so from
there the rice is ready to go and you
just have to be washed before it's
so we just like to take out the pro sire
and the D lot of stuff for helping us
out
and for will flow from window rights or
giving us our rice so if you guys have
any questions just thank you for
listening
we did a good job so we visited or I
guess I didn't I went to a store
so it is available and the community
pregnant that we worked with actually
they were the ones who brought us there
so they would be able to supply the
what fraction of your rights remain
broken in
third eye what we were really concerned
with was how much like the percentage of
hospital like D huh stress could like
you can eat that the nurses man is like
it's not nice you would rather not eat
but for the most part we would rather
err on the side of the husband most
their rights versus leaving it husband
hall so it was probably about a third of
it was probably broken we lost
maybe about a maybe about like between
five and ten percent of it was like just
like sand grainy size so it was good we
have something that people can adjusted
returns to so if they would care for
having more customers and
themselves then event probably lots for
instance it's not gonna be as tight or
not to be crushing it as much
and something else we learned from the
community partners that currently when
they they currently bring it to a mill
at the house and when they get it back
some pieces do still have tusks on and
pieces are broken so it's not
what they currently have is something
similar
and they could theoretically cycle the
that's what we found was really nice
about this we weren't quite expecting
this going or shaking oh look at that
like all the hush noises like right in
the center so okay so we just scooped it
ll out just put it back with the rice
that hasn't been processed yet this is
that you used yes so this is the fact
that the system is sort of irrelevant
like we're just we just happen to use a
sieve so yeah exactly yeah and so it
would just be of I can like a fairly
shallow container so the fact that the
system doesn't really it it isn't the
one that's causing it to you realize
though is really important that like the
bottom was relatively flat and sturdy
and that the sides wouldn't Bend so you
wouldn't want like a plastic container
because you can't get the right motion
for that's shaking back and forth great
to separate
but we just actually used the same
container that we are winnowing in so we
could I mean we didn't we don't have the
huge like platters that they sort of use
but that would definitely be something
that will suggest a suppressor and try
and have them try it out to see if it
works
good afternoon everyone thank you for
coming our group project is Beryl on
fire charcoal desire my name is Jessica
our tilith and along with the in Zenon
Kurt's will we went to Savannah Banda in
Nicaragua and we really introduced and
we helped the women make charcoal out of
Agri waste so for context of charcoal in
the community of Savannah rounding in
about 2009 a professor named events are
visited the Community Initiatives
charcoal over the years the knowledge
has lost the women lost practice they
catch out they had challenges they
didn't yield perhaps when they tried to
make it they were getting less than
tempura cuts per year so we went this
spring Brittany girl we reintroduce the
process to four women whom we now call
of charcoal captains and when we were
there our yields were our yield of burns
were coming up to around 80 because of
her burn since then we came back we
redesigned the charcoal making process
we make the innovations send them back
up feedback and results and when they've
done their with our new designs they're
getting up 210 packets per granny so the
project is looking commercially viable
for them they're looking at making the
charcoal for the restaurant that's on
site to fuel and to cook with they're
going to be making charcoal to sell to
the community and they're actually
displaying in their community fairness
and in Maine on how to make charcoal and
how to sell it so the way that we
identified the problem was looking at
that recurrent charcoal burning process
it requires lighting this oil drum on
fire which is packed with dry biomass
and then sealing both the bottom and the
top so this process right now with the
barrel standing on top of the three
bricks is optimized for cost so this is
the most low-cost way to do it however
we felt like we could add improvements
that would be justified in their cost
because this has two main problems one
is the issue of heat exposure so the
user actually has to get quite close to
the barrel to be able to kick out the
bricks from the bottom and the second is
the safety issue where the where in
sealing the bottom of the barrel you
have to Tim it and this could result in
some accidents
so as you can see their flames coming
out of the bottom of the barrel as
they're doing this so that's the heat
problem and then as they're tipping it
the peril fell over and and almost land
on one of the woman so this is a safety
concern and there was also a lot of
biomass to the left of the barrel so it
could have lit all that on fire too all
right so how do we sell this our
solution consists of a circular cutout
that is slightly smiling circumference
than the barrel and with my Doggett
sends three air channels and within each
with two air channel is our two bricks
that are embedded and the girl simply
sits on top of the ground again on top
of the bricks were like a very stable
setup when we tested our solution we
want to make sure that the biomass can
still be lit pretty easily through the
bottom what we found was that actually
it's a lot easier because the air
channels actually block anyway back
with interview process we also
calculated the the size of the air
shells needed to be till about the
necessary airflow for a very thorough
burn you can see on the sides of the
barrel is sealed in the ground except
for by the air channels and because the
ground because the barrel sits at ground
level they eliminate the risk of having
to tip over the barrel or having to
handle or move barrel oh it's on fire
eventually you'll need to cut off the
air supply to the bird and biomass to
lots of car guys and so the way we
figured we would seal these aerials is
through these metal plates so the idea
behind these equations for the user to
be able to slide a metal plate from a
distance keeping a safe distance so that
they're not exposed to the kita as much
and through several design iterations
this is our final design we came up with
its you can hook it up if you get a one
piece of sheet metal which is very
readily available in in raga and the
handle is made by making slits in the
sheet metal and curving it around and
riveting it to connect at the top and
riveting is very
so yeah we just these metal shears to
cut the sheet metal so it's pretty
simple if you have a video of Craig
monitoring use of these
does for easily maintain their distance
and it's pretty quick
and that is our solution
but they question that came up when
stealing the girl was whether or not we
shouldn't seal the bottom first the top
first when he found to experimentation
that it was easiest to first seal using
the middle seals so we cut off air close
to the flames aren't this intense coming
out of the top and then you can throw on
the lake on the top and then that allows
for smoke come out of any air hat air
gaps or air will seep in so you know
where it exactly to plug Sanjay from
evolution we actually delivered this to
the header size and Jessica was telling
you about your feedback we got
so our coop is unique in that we are
able to have a native speaker feet
communicate with the women constantly
become communication with them through
emails phone calls to their cell phones
to various women and men moms like well
this is a picture of what makes it their
own barrel dugout again we had our
design and we submitted it to them you
know a document of here's what you
should do new and innovative and so they
did the barrel tuck out and they try it
they mean their own she metal designs to
cover the barrel so we only send
pictures of ours but they went ahead and
they said we're already going to make
another design iteration we love the
idea we asking questions about you know
how do you feel about the safety risk
and I said
risk of the barrel falling over now
which is just as important as the heat
we asked them how how do you like
cooking with the charcoal now they said
I cook tortillas which is another most
valued foods and they said with the
charcoal we made those exceeds were
delicious I have a credential at the
charcoal they're gonna be using and
those Lynch is like a bread critical
recipe they're going to be using the
charcoal now that they feel safe enough
to continue to use it we're going to be
using it in the community fair this
mid-may and
lighting the biomass is also an
advantage we that was very fast they all
have to do with a line at the bottom of
the holes on the bottom of the barrel
with the air channels and now when they
went to lighting it was easier to light
because it was Quinn protection so in
conclusion in summary we've taken to the
charcoal making process and added four
point of making it easier for anyway the
points to the process we've made the
lighting of the barrel easier because
now and you're getting the match under
the barrel it's when detectives so the
windmill put it out now while the barrel
is burning for those 15 sometimes 25
minutes it's cooler the flames are
coming out from under the bottom
radially outwards repeat now the sealing
of the bear
safer because there's no longer tipping
king method by another season metal
sheets and it's faster to the steel as
well because it doesn't require
coordination and I invited was slipped
the metal sheet so throughout the
process of developing the solution we
did some experiments around where the
heat was coming from and we discover
that most of us coming from thermal
radiation from the barrel so we thought
okay a way that we could improve our
solution even more is to develop
radiation shields and the kind of the
gold standard of radiation shields is
aluminum tin foil but we ruled this out
because it is just too brittle and
wouldn't be able to withstand the
thermal cycles of a barrel burning again
and again so we experimented with two
others as well here you have like window
screening this is made out of aluminum
and galvanized steel metal mesh and the
conclusion was that it wouldn't be it
wouldn't justify the cost the heat
reduction wouldn't justify the cost so
what you see in this graph is the cost
of insulation going up on the x-axis and
that's as measured by more and more
layers of either the metal sheet or the
window or the window screen and on the
y-axis you have percentage of heat
reduction so you do see a positive
correlation
of that insulation that you seer that
you put on the market reduction you get
however spending upwards of fifteen
dollars doesn't even get you 40%
reduction so where does this leave our
solution well we think that the dugout
and metal play seals really represent
kind of a sweet spot like in a range of
solutions at the very top you just have
the typical typical kick method and then
you you know you can introduce the
dugout and just seal the holes with sand
but that's that wouldn't give you as
much heat reduction and ours is medium
cost the sheet metal is not that
expensive to make the plates out of and
it gets you a significant key reduction
and finally adding some kind of
radiation shields is pretty high cost
but doesn't and gives you more reduction
in heat but we don't think that it
really justifies the cost so we have a
lot of people to think
I will beat them all out I think we are
just about done but we are looking
forward to your questions and any
feedback you might have
that's a great question we thought about
that a lot but when we introduced so we
done but when we introduced that sheet
metal they said sure we'll do it and
again they made one set of this design
of the sheet metal and they're ready to
make another set with another with so
another another batch of supplies to
make another set of sheet metal so it
doesn't seem like it's a restrictive
cost for them we like we are that is one
thing that we neglected to look into and
but we know it's there on site because
they use this type of sheet metal for
their solar ovens so we know they can
obtain it and then I don't think they
had to go out and buy it or anything
because already had in there centered so
our our case is kind of special and that
make you have these resources
it seems like the topping method still
involves getting close to the barrel
where everything else you maintain
distance from the barrel we consider
just putting a popper riveting a small
handle on top of the top piece so that
you can also put that on the first thing
that's really interesting we actually on
in the design that's women made
that's a good question about the way the
design of women made in Nicaragua they
put a handle on their metal sheet and
they said that for our second iteration
that they're gonna make they're gonna
take out the handle because you realize
it's it's unnecessary if it's they said
it's not that hot you can get close to
it and just insert it with your hand
that's what they're doing
so there's doesn't even have the little
hole or the let's handle that we've made
for our designs so they're there okay
wait I think you were talking about the
top right yeah yeah they have one where
it's like the circular metal plate that
we have here and there's like basically
like a pot handle over as they
we are tight on time so I'm going to
cancel question very much you know where
to find is going to have any more than
that in the corner thank you
I'm across er and Carter Chang so our
project is sealing the plastic bag
sealer - then we've developed during our
trip down to Nicaragua over spring break
where we were fact-finding and analyzing
the four different projects we were
looking at and we just developed this
one for the remainder of the semester
we're driving accretions the first other
describe the situation we found in MLR
which is the community that we visited
in Nicaragua they have a large orange
crop that could get twice a year and
very manageable with every community -
every similar community has that same
orange crop so they can't really settle
those oranges on any type of
because the markets flooded so the goal
is to basically develop a way for them
to preserve that orange product for us
it's in the form of juice so they can
sell when there is a market for oranges
so we presented this project was first
of all in last year's class and we
presented that version of you know water
to the women of the community who will
be using this product and the
presentation thought we had some
technical difficulties because we went
down expecting to go to run the device
off of the 12-volt car battery but when
we got there we realized that since the
last group had gone down last spring
break
they had just installed a microfiber
grid and they now had 120 volts AC
coming out of a wall socket and so
nobody really had total car batteries
for us the power of the device so we
strung out a bunch of double-a and
triple-a batteries to be able to do with
cold pack seals and there was a lot of
excitement about this device while we
were
we gathered around and we
a couple bag sealers for the double-a
batteries that we just happen to have
any backpacks or totally drink so
that's basically just the project to be
able to create something that they can
use in this community and also could be
adapted to it
see who's orange juice or whatever kind
of thing that are trying to preserve
and they have a pasteurization process
that comes before this back ceiling that
they use so this vaccine is the second
step of that process and we work with
also Phoenix
Christian Nicaraguan NGO they justice
tamil development and energy work with
rural communities in the area
okay so awesome eunuchs now we're
incredibly grateful for and all this a
lot
however they render the first prototype
also leaked obsolete so we had a couple
improvements to make after those after
this this was the first version as you
can see a kind of permanent circuit that
they was prefabricated the most
expensive part of the entire advice a
hinge that they had bought and a latch
that was kind of sticking a pool
therefore we wanted to kind of fix the
remedy this in working 2.0 we also
wanted to kind of incorporate a clue the
things that we learned in Nicaragua a
that there is not really a reliable
power source we wanted to meet both DC
and AC needs to do this we hooked up a
we got a adapter that can go from the
wall outlet wall AC power and output 12
DC volts also you could just take those
we save leads and move them up to
DC volt battery and achieve the same
effect second off Alyssa's
pasteurization process we didn't really
know about it about much about it for
the initial prototype but after going to
over a wire we didn't learn that the
pasteurization process is there we just
have to get the oxygen out so we you
know had these two parameters in place
while we were trying to fix the design
so the air removal process getting all
the air out and ergonomics were also
factors in the design and this would
lead to us kind of exploring several
different orientations first off a
vertical sealer whether it was hanging
off from the edge of a table or
dismounted like that it wasn't really
conducive to user friendliness you had
to hold the bag in place it was kind of
difficult to get a you know clean seal
without any air in it it wasn't really
the best next to handheld device kind of
like a clamp that you can just put in
place on the hanging bag it had a lot of
moving parts
we felt it wouldn't be the easiest thing
to scrounge through those parts see
Nicaragua it was you know kind of kind
of a lot of fabrication involved last
but not least we had a horizontal sealer
moves similar to version 1.00 with a
prototype last year our biggest problem
with this was a it was messy it got our
nice juice that was running off
everywhere and it was harder to get a
airtight seal as a result also just
economics pressing on it again and again
and again it was kind of difficult so in
order to kind of make the best of both
worlds we decided to combine both
vertical sealing and horizontal
stealing the two most feasible and put
it at 45 degrees perfect split anyway so
this is the cad model of our design the
reason we wanted to put it at 45 degrees
was to allow kind of a path for the
runoff to go into a bowl underneath and
it's also why it's elevated also it's
kind of easier to smooth out the bag and
get all the air out when you're doing
this a lot easier to kind of chop at the
water level or put the arm down at the
water level and get all the air air out
so with this design in mind we have
actually led to our final product so
this as you can see our final products
because I don't decide on the 45 degree
angle for usability and just for
functionality one of our great
improvements is the latch so originally
the last was a wireless hanging out that
people would have to manually pull with
a significant amount of force but and
this is orientation we have a easy
sprint spring held latch where all I
have to do is quickly push those uh the
daisyland and another improvement is the
circuitry
so the first of all it's not that they
know the power adapter we couldn't even
just bought date put into the wall power
adapter we did look into making our own
things without bringing the power down
but we found that this was B but for the
simplest option and comparable in price
to any others so I ended up going with
the buy a premade the circuit in the
previous design was very expensive it
was premade timing board and one of the
places that the other team had actually
thought of as place for improvement was
to design a separate timing circuit so
we did that we put it on the side here
so the fail ideas visible it's just a
lm5 satisfy the timer if anyone's
familiar with those and the circuitry to
make it so that we can change the time
from about three seconds to about 30
seconds for different temperatures of
juice and
thicknesses of plastic and stuff so the
Camille 4chan Deena is actually in there
so you would set it get it right for one
day and then put it back up and you turn
it on by hitting a button but sets off
the timer there's a light here that
would go on
we've actually got it so the timer turns
on the neck room key element for a
certain amount of time which melts the
bag and then the LED will stay on for
about five seconds after the nichrome
heat has turned off because you're
sweating five seconds is good so that
the plastic isn't like still perfectly
melted when you're trying to pick it up
and so you don't burn yourself when you
found that counting it on your own it
was very difficult especially if you're
excited about stealing your first bags
of juice and stuff so who made the LED
stay on longer to give it very clear
this is when you take it out looking at
the cost of the product originally the
version 1.0 cost about $56 for all the
materials we were able to cut that in
half with the additional functionality
of our products we were able to ensure
the airtight seal in addition to have a
very usable latch system in addition
a great timing circuit us compatible
with their their AC power down there in
addition that's in terms of
implementation we plan to deliver our
products awesome Phoenix a me in August
I believe it will be the product down
there in addition to that we will have a
user manual in English and Spanish with
these respects in addition to the
additional circuits just in case repairs
and then also things to help distribute
to the end users we'd like to thank AUSA
Phoenix our mentor Ken namely these deal
out of MIT as well as the our software
designer for allowing us to visit venues
are there any questions
have that
Oh
your guard actually someone else been
careless
coumadin is our homemade Nicaraguan
orange juice lemon fresh this morning
so we have the little bag a little ball
here just in case this excess spill so
we have this wire that's obviously not
using all the capacity because we don't
know what size of bags that the much
they use they can be doing personal good
size bags they sell on buses or other
simple situations or they could making
kind of like more wholesale to your size
bags that they sell to restaurants or
so we have the night long record wire
this is back here I'll be able to guide
our so this lever doesn't for this arm
is a jiggle back so we created airtight
seal like simple through the juice sit
down here with an excess juice come out
into the bowl you press the button he
was on
to tell us when it's ready
so we've adjusted timing because we've
been playing with these bags all day the
idea being that you won't have to adjust
it if you're doing kind of large batches
of bagging your juice
we haven't adjusted since we lost
eternity this morning yeah it's been
really fun so the Eagles oh yeah the
potentiometers inside that house in
there so it's a seal when there is the
light of orange juice
where the back
so there that'd be the suspects that we
found there's similar thickness to the
bags that were provided to us by also
Phoenix and I by
or the community in El revoir yeah good
old purchase every purchase on long
tubes and we would seal up the bottom
and make the Medusa and simple
so they would seal the bottom using that
yes yes
for you machine plastic
or silence treatment
and how long how many bags you have to
go through in the adjustment process to
get it I think I did about three seals
this morning to get it set up right and
not what is you can do that with water
periodically even though the water at
baby I mean it was this one temperature
the juice we like fresh from the store
juice and it was all cold had in about
five seconds to the time
like yeah free trust so there are a
couple little variables you have to
juggle there's the thickness of the
plastic the temperature of the liquid
inside also we found really pulpy juice
and as the time as well hopefully they
wouldn't waste too much plastic in the
process what we eventually ended up
doing was kind of making a seal seeing
if it works if it's no manage to make
another seal see if it works oh we
didn't waste that much plastic girl yeah
it was like three seals on one bag on my
back Aaron so there was one bag that was
like not this pretty but still
so we have it up we use a silicon based
adhesive around the base we add that
he's the front oh sorry we had that it
needs around the LEDs and the switch g5
that's been spray-painted we've got at
least rate notes we can pull it off the
baby now they just oh that's why that
screwdriver on
so it's watertight for
and yeah we decided on using PVC since
that was actually one of the motion to
vote under one of the cheapest
components we encountered in hardware
stores in Nicaragua it was something
like 2 cents for PVC connectors and I'm
sure - equal to 2 so yeah it's keeping
Gerizim
is the idea would make the circuitry
themselves or people listening we
probably would
probably make more or you're the best
way for it to be made in the karuppa we
have a certain diagram
be part of these
is there any intelligence
so I guess that's you wouldn't plug it
in
you would follow the
but I guess in here
the nice thing is that you know when
it's pressed in place it's it's you know
pretty much completely sealed and this
is teflon tape and the nichrome wire
itself pulls off pretty easily teflon
tape with that's cool you know we've
we've kind of been touching this all day
right after it would say like easily
appropriate
mmm-hmm if it does if it does get turned
on
way like it doesn't turn on it's been
farmers
the arms open for its nocturnal if they
wanted to connect it to a 12-volt DC
battery what would they do
we've got these today for simplicity
strung together but you just take these
two leads and instead of sputtering and
touching them two wires that have an
adapter got some tip hooks come a
battery
you